a day after a Mudslide swallowed a
highway in central Colombia rescue crews
called off the search for survivors they
say at least 34 people on a bus in a car
and on a motorcycle were killed on
Sunday at least eight of the victims
were children Rescuers did find nine
survivors
amongst the people we could rescue alive
was a seven-year-old girl who was right
now at the San Jorge de Pereira hospital
with some minor injuries unfortunately
we found her clinging to her deceased
mother her brother also died there
a boy a little over a year during the
major tragedy we are going through
this is the latest catastrophe of
Colombia's rainy season which started in
August officials say the weather pattern
called La Nina has intensified this
year's storms mudslides and floods have
killed more than 200 people and
displaced a half million residents this
year
officials say they will try to step up
reforestation programs to prevent future
mudslides and loss of life
Russell and Jordan Al Jazeera